[Musique]
mais moi je m'appelle your ass je viens
de la capitale et on m'a envoyé ici
parce qu'il ya un fils de dragon
techniquement je suis obligé d'un oblige
j'ai obligé de faire une cérémonie pour
bien officialiser le truc avec son
affront
il adore ça allait bouger les
cérémonials
[Musique]
à élise de lieux raison non mais je sais
qui vous êtes c'est pas la peine am
cérémonie donc j'ai obligé de faire ces
prix ne parlait pas je sais gérer bc2
mais je suis stressé j'ai pas l'habitude
et déboule à élise lior vous avez
survécu au bûcher souvent par là même
que vous êtes un vrai fils du dragon la
capitale vous octroie donc le titre de
seigneur à élise your dragon mais aussi
un gars de royal une armure du dragon en
héritage de vos aïeux et par décision du
roi vous qu gèrerez le petit royaume des
fraudes c'est quoi qu coin vous qu'on
jurerait sait gérer à deux en fait
mais au fait c'est très flatteur pour
les lycéens mais il refuse
j'accepte athlètes si je refuse ou des
aux bestiaux un oui alors j'ai dit si la
priorité de la capitale et l'entente
avec 6 réalise seniors b lire à partir
d'aujourd'hui partager votre pouvoir
avec 6 réalise du dragon c'est compris
est-ce que c'est compris c'est hyper
gênant
[Musique]
ma famille est de sens noble elle a
construit ce château pierre par pierre
mes ancêtres au prix de nombreux
sacrifices ont obtenu le statut de
seigneur bien c'est la première réunion
du conseil depuis la décision injuste du
roi donc quel et l'injuste ordre du jour
l'insécurité croissante dans notre
région c'est vrai ça ça craint s'il ya
même des vols deux royaumes et ou contre
la violence je propose la culture
j'aimerais organiser des pièces de
théâtre c'est des petites histoires
qu'on raconte aux gens avec une morale à
la fin comme tu es
c'est mal voler c'est mal nos travers
son seigneur c'est mal ça nous
permettrait de les éduquer et de leur
apprendre à penser par eux-mêmes
apprendre aux gens à penser par
eux-mêmes un an les pauvres c'est bien
pour d'autant qu'ils savent pas qu'ils
sont pauvres
c'est tout l'intérêt du truc mais la
culture c'est primordial les histoires
ça leur permettrait de supporter leur
quotidien as le plus gros taux de
mortalité du pays les gens meurent de la
peste et du choléra les gens ils veulent
pas d histoire ils veulent de la pommade
péter histoire c'est un peu la pommade
pour l'esprit je suis parti en impro non
proposition suivante alors de mon côté
je propose de créer des soirées
dansantes dans les villages
cela permettrait aux hommes et aux
femmes de se rencontrer de façon plus
civilisé les rencontres se sont pas déjà
civilisé la plupart des unions sont
forcés et alors puisqu'il est ce là
veulent maintenant que les hommes et les
femmes arriverait bien habillé on
apprendrait des petits pas de danse et
c'est à dire combien de temps ok c'est
super et ça lui est bon et à quel moment
on déplore la puce allant des fleurs
rien du tout et le droit de cuissage 1
des seniors ils ont droit de faire ça
c'est un privilège ancestrale sûr on
peut changer la loire non
et toi qu'est ce que tu en penses
moi je m'en fous un peu je veux dire ne
trouves tu pas qu'aider les femmes à
choisir leurs époux c'est un changement
aussi positif que tu as cogestion du
royaume le mako gestion du royaume est
très positif oui j'aime beaucoup ça le
la danse et le théâtre
ouais ah oui parce que tout ce qu'il a
dit c'était super enfin merci merci
c'est noël voilà donc ça fait il y
aurait lé seigneur à hélices et moi pour
la danse et le théâtre
trois votes pour la culture c'est ça
comme je le pressentais cette cogestion
ça peut être possible
clarisse délire on est d'accord que
cette histoire de coups je suis
accueilli ce jeu c'est n'importe quoi
alors vous me demandez est ce que tu
pourrais pas faire ce que font les
femmes
c'est à dire ce que ferait femme quoi tu
le sais lui avec un philtre d'amour
après tu coucher avec lui de façon
totalement débridée et puis dans son
sommeil et à spears on a le regard
tourné vers les flammes
la juillet je peux pas faire ça pourquoi
parce que je suis pas une sorcière
bien sûr que non personne est une
sorcière
je ne tue pas les gens ok
tu mets ton c'est gentil de me donne un
coup de main je crois même que c'est la
première fois pour un début à tout en
revanche cette histoire de cohabitation
ça fait un petit peu peur pour harry
ellis décision du roi on peut réagir
pour le moment mais on vend beaucoup de
poison un accident c'est vite arrivé
non non non c'est très rare les
accidents dont royaume mais imaginons qu
une fiole ces gars là comme ça c'est
possible ça non parce que moi je fais
très attention toutefois si l'eau une
fiole qui ces gars là on s'est produit
c'est quand même possible ça non tenez
en télé gatif sur elle et qui tu veux
rendre fou pour faire soi même
bon ben c'est bien un encore une bonne
réunion qui se termine on peut y aller
bonne soirée
les mystères sont luis a